las llamas que consumen a grecia y
turquía han obligado a los bomberos y
equipos de emergencia a trabajar día y
noche los incendios cercana la capital
atenas amenazando incluso el icónico
sitio arqueológico donde nacieron los
juegos olímpicos el país se enfrenta a
una crisis medioambiental sin
precedentes con múltiples y grandes
incendios en muchas partes del país el
resultado de una ola de calor que entra
ahora en su segunda semana en turquía
los incendios han provocado evacuaciones
masivas y han destruido cientos de
hogares rescate a mis animales los llevé
al pueblo vecino al pueblo de caoba
donde está mi cuñada acabo de regresar
mi casa está en peligro de quemarse el
servicio de monitoreo de la atmósfera de
la unión europea alertó de los incendios
que la región mediterránea significa
para el planeta advirtiendo de grandes
cantidades de humo en la atmósfera
mientras tanto se espera que las olas de
calor que amenazan el sur europeo
continúen hasta el fin de semana